post Malone goes up on stage falls into  a hole allegedly breaks a bunch of ribs  did you see the video  now the crazy thing is and I don't know  post but like like I know how I am I  want a thing a certain way even if they  tell me it's dangerous because who could  fall into it context Radio City Music  Hall he wanted to use everything and I  remember the person from MSG was like  just because you can use everything it's  not a la carte yeah and I'm just like  what's he usually wants to use it the  other thing I came up when I did this so  whatever like that that was a 15 foot 20  foot drop what about that when I was  going up are you worried again you're  slice yeah that's crazy I was like if  what if I just got really nervous and I  passed out here just my arm leaned in  just destroyed would you finish the show  though yeah of course of course I'm  gonna finish the show you were facing  forward you good thing your nose didn't  get wrong